is it kind of like that whole scene like
is it kind of bittersweet that it's
coming to an end
definitely I'm mostly it's sad because I
can't stalk Ted Danson anymore every
summer although will it stop me
no but it's we end the show so
beautifully and it's so rare that the
creators get a chance to make the call
and when you say goodbye yeah normally a
layer Network just pulls the plug and so
it's amazing to have planned this a year
in advance and to soak up all of what
makes it beautiful and it's such a good
ending everyone's gonna cry no one's
gonna be okay so I can't believe I found
out this is actually the good place is
your first acting job cuz you I know you
were hosting in England before but this
year first that's a hell of a first job
I didn't was my first ever time acting
and so I went in and I think maybe
because I was so sure I wouldn't get the
job I had that kind of reckless abandon
abut just a maniac on the loose
and he took that as confidence that you
also promote body positivity you have a
campaign a movement called away right
yeah it's a body in your trolley
so why is this important to you so Iowa
is a body neutrality movement it's about
getting away from thinking about your
body and instead thinking about the
things in your life that you should be
grateful for like I weigh the sum of all
my parts I weigh Mike you can't measure
my worth on a weighing scale you can't
measure your own like that it's insane
that we still do this to women in this
day and age so it's about like you know
I weigh my relationship my contribution
to society my financial independence my
activism that's what I weigh that's my
birth and so it's a movement where we
have almost a million followers and we
get five or six thousand more a day if
people from everywhere from all walks of
life who are just tired of being
undermined and underestimated by society
and it's this really beautiful space
that I'm launching into a company next
year and we're gonna take this as we
take this as far as we can and we're
changing laws and changing global
policies together I think sometimes we
focus so much on the aesthetics of what
health looks like instead of actual
health like and what's going on inside
your body and we just don't know you
know so it's like what's going on in
someone's life so it's I think it's a
really important thing you're doing
especially because you have such a big
spotlight on you so thank you for doing
that
Thanks you can prove somebody's shame I
have no idea your furniture I literally
I'm getting trolled right now online
wild I am I
I remember you going through that and
then very shortly afterwards I gained a
lot of weight back in England I was a
radio DJ by the way you couldn't even
see me you just had people just wanted
to know I was thinner over the airwaves
so I got nationally fat shamed for like
six months in my own country and it was
your response to yours that gave me the
strength to get through it like did I
use a word that I can't family
it is a great campaign though and thank
you so much for doing it it's important
like I said because even small it's
important for all of us we have small
eyes to do something really cool outside
of our egocentric lives you know so you
can catch jameelah though I was seeing
this series the misery index Tuesday's
on TBS and also watch her in the final
episode of the good place Thursdays on
NBC I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this